all right now pay attention son hope
well son are you paying attention are
you paying close attention are you
looking really really really really
close good epic dog oh okay there was
more I didn't really I didn't realize it
was close well maybe if I stay here well
I'm still not dead still technically
alive and I can win this come on win it
for family I don't know if I have any
family but I'm gonna win it barely
that's the best kind of winning
lightsaber to click I got a clip it's
been awhile since I played this game
they made a lot of updates purple
lightsaber I just want to be like mace
windu okay this is not okay hi hi
don't mind me heads keep exploding oh
god why sad to know you have to deliver
presents oh oh
hi lady you don't see your family oh
that's when I say oh hey hungry I choose
the jiggly balls that's kind of what I
do in life I just look around for balls
to fondle and caress and rub my wheels
all over is gonna work out well but I'm
about whole maybe I can still hey okay
there's no oh okay this no cheating here
Oh
Danger Danger Danger okay that was the
danger line I discovered it ah is what
we were supposed to do
you can't Wow oh my god I cannot believe
I survived that I'm doing good throw
yourself not here wait Oh son you
weren't supposed to let goodbye
am I gonna win oh boy Oh son toy
Oh torture machine neon Oh press C press
ctrl hold up oh oh oh oh okay and he's
fine oh I'm not doing anything I'm just
waiting for him to burst into blood okay
Oh God
doing it again come on there we go
wow I got this I'm a winner I'm a winner
I'm a winner I'm a winner I'm the best
oh I'm in the rhythm I'm in the rhythm
I'm in the rhythm of the night til the
morning light
Oh moon run original I don't know what
makes it risen okay okay all right okay
we made it
well I made it son didn't make it what
do I care
oh you want to go up against me I know
all about the sports and the field goals
Hey oh well um Pass me the ball
Pass me the pigskin Oh Oh another poon
dodged punishment
you're a douche I'm not good with the
Pogo
yeah that's what I thought you suck Oh
in the brag baby
Oh miss me yeah by that much good stay
down that's okay missing testicle but I
gained a penis glitchy rainbow like
crossing over and oh oh I don't think I
crossed over correctly oh lordy Lou that
like a horrible reverse birth here we go
ow
oh god it's so gross I have to go slower
or something I don't I don't I don't
know how to win these how do you win
these how are these winnable oh so it's
like a tumors growing out of your neck
ready for the smackdown oh where am I oh
yeah you ready for this Mac down wait
you're all right you want you won that
round
but this round goes marry you ready for
Dolph all right third time's charm dude
don't mess around with me you go we're
gonna have a loving embrace
fudge goddamn it now you go down
sassafras
hey Scott you this time well but a big
bang my butthole oh I got you then
winner me thank you survived what bye
I'm an old man I forgot my old man plays
my grandma Oh Oh suck on those nards
baby who the winner today this has been
happy wheels highlights thanks for
watching if you want to see more happy
wheels right now check the description
or click the annotation for the full
happy wheels playlist and if you want to
see more happy wheels in the future
please click the like button to let me
know thanks again everyone and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye